تجدد للشبكات بالاسلحه الثقيله في السودان
رغم الهدنه
بايدن يثير سخريه حول انقاذ بروسي
للاقتصاد قبل ولادتها
[موسيقى]
وامراه تخدش 400 سياره بكندا وشرطه تبحث
عنها
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
نبدا من السودان حيث افاد مراسل العربيه
بتجدد الاشتباكات بالاسلحه الثقيله شمال
الخرطوم بحري في ثاني ايام الهدنه
والاتفاق على وقف اطلاق النار بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع هذا وجددت السعوديه
والولايات المتحده التاكيد على اهميه
اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار في السودان اذ اكدت
الخارجيه السعوديه في بيان ان الشعب
السوداني بحاجه مساء للمساعده الانسانيه
وعوده الخدمه الاساسيه فيما قال المفاوض
السامي للامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين
فيليبوغراندي الاربعاء ان اكثر من 300 الف
شخص فرو من السودان الى البلدان المجاوره
حتى الان
[موسيقى]
في مصر شهدت محكمه اسره اغرب قضيه خلع في
البلاد لسيده تدعى ريهام بسبب معاناتها مع
سلفتها اي زوجه شقيقها التي لا تنجب
تقارير بان المشكلات بين ريهام وسلفتها
بدات عقب انجاب ريهام رضيعها الاول ليكون
هو سبب الخلافات بينهما اذا تدعي زوجه
شقيق زوجها ان ريهام صارت تهتم اكثر
برضيعها من حماتها الامر الذي اثار غضب
ريهام وشعرت بالغيره لتقوم بشكايتها
لزوجها الذي اعتبر بدوره ايضا ان الاهتمام
شيء طبيعي لكنها اصرت على حل مشكلتها
بنفسها لتتجه للمحكمه وترفع دعوى خلع
للتخلص من الاثنين معا زوجها وسلفتها
الى المكسيك هذه المره حيث اعلنت السلطات
ان بركان بوفو الواقع على بعد 70 كيلومترا
جمال جنوب شرق العاصمه مكسيكو وصل قصف
رماد وغارات او غازات مشيره الى ان مستوى
التحذير من اخطاره لا يزال على حاله اقل
بخطوه واحده من درجه الخطر القصوى وسائل
الاعلام المحليه افادت بوقوع انفجارين
وهزه ارضيه جرى هذا النشاط البركاني فيما
كانت السلطات قد رفعت الاحد مستوى التحذير
من اخطر هذا البركان درجه واحده من صفر
اثنين الى اصفر ثلاثه او من اصفر اثنين
الى اصفر ثلاثه وهذا المستوى يسبق بدرجه
واحده مستوى الانذار الاحمر وهو درجه
الخطر القصوى
[موسيقى]